[Música]
y como lo venimos adelantando se
inauguran en beijing china los juegos
olímpicos de invierno en medio de las
restricciones por el commit 19 y el
boicot diplomático encabezado por eeuu
es que a lo largo de la historia de
estos juegos olímpicos' la acción
política ha boicoteado la participación
de sus deportistas en cinco ediciones el
primer gran boicot a unos juegos
olímpicos se produjo en
1956 esto en melbourne en australia
parece entonces países como españa suiza
países bajos justificaron su decisión en
la invasión de hungría por parte de la
unión soviética pero qué pasa ahora en
esta edición de las justas deportivas
para ello entonces quiero darle el paso
a nuestro primer invitado al día alex
carlos veríssimo estará estará se
analista política exterior experto en
temas de china y también eeuu gracias
carlos por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 porque esta
politización del deporte desde cuando
vemos entonces estas situaciones y
hablemos un poco de la historia
buen día buen día a todos en resumen
hecho por rosa pérez es real la
politización del deporte se ha dado es
algo que se viene dando con cierta
frecuencia ya en 1936
tuvimos el saludo nazi en los juegos
olímpicos de berlín como bien decía el
evento de 1956 y en
1968 dos deportistas norteamericanos
hacen el saludo de las panteras negras
un evento que fue altamente con una
repercusión muy alta y fue altamente
difundido por todo eeuu recordemos lo
que las panteras negras era un grupo
afrodescendiente norteamericano que
estaba buscándola de alguna forma
terminar con los con las diferencias
sociales y raciales que existían allí
pero también tenemos en 1976 más de 20
países africanos bloquean y no van no
asisten
de alguna forma denunciando en la parte
de sudáfrica hay un evento muy
interesante donde los propios
neozelandeses son obligados a intentar
no jugar sus partidos de rugby porque
habían jugado algunos partidos con
sudáfrica pero el evento más interesante
de toda esta cadena se da en 1980 donde
eeuu no concurre no asiste no manda a
sus deportistas a los juegos de moscú
denunciando la invasión que se había
dado en afganistán y es acompañada por
una serie de países entre ellos de
actividad de américa del sur argentina
chile paraguay uruguay bolivia y panamá
previene la parte más increíble de todo
esto los que no asisten también no
mandan a sus deportistas son los chinos
los chinos en ese momento tenía una
distancia importante con rusia por ende
algunas noticias que están saliendo en
estos días que estamos regresando a la
guerra fría creo que tienen que ser
nuevamente analizadas
veamos que también en 1984 en represalia
los propios el bloque comunista no
asiste a los juegos olímpicos de los
arts
ahora carlos parece que esto ha cambiado
ahora rusia y china están digamos más
cerca que nunca además con esta reunión
que tuvo xi jinping con vladimir putin
hablemos entonces también de los dos
protagonistas en este en este boicot
china evidentemente donde se está
realizando estos juegos olímpicos de
invierno y eeuu además también le quiero
preguntar por qué en esta ecuación eeuu
decidió solamente hacer un boicot
diplomático pero sí enviar a sus atletas
entonces cuál es el mensaje digamos
porque si quisiera hacer un boicot
completo pues evidentemente como usted
lo dijo como lo hizo años atrás
simplemente no manda tampoco sus atletas
muy bien en algunos otros casos los
atletas estaban prohibidos de asistir y
concursar con las banderas de sus países
en otros boicots y que hicieron
concursaron con la bandera de los juegos
olímpicos o sea que de alguna forma hubo
este también una competencia por parte
de sus atletas y volvieron con su
medallero a sus países creo que eeuu
está intentando un boicot diferente
mucho más suave que los que hemos tenido
en el pasado recordemos que también los
antecedentes del 2008 son importantes el
2008 los juegos beijing tuvieron
estuvieron tenidos por algunas denuncias
de abusos y tuvimos aquello de una flor
por tíbet las denuncias a los tibetanos
etcétera etcétera hoy por el lo que
tenemos es que no sólo eeuu el que está
voy con el boicot diplomático a esto se
suman también inglaterra canadá
australia en diciembre china de alguna
forma amenaza diciendo de que va a haber
algún tipo de repercusión bueno hoy al
día de hoy también se han sumado
japón-nueva zelanda estonia bélgica
lituania y kosovo ellos no envían sus
diplomáticos pero no significa que no
vayan sus deportistas hacia allá ahora
carlos también le quiero preguntar
entonces por qué si el gobierno chino
estaba acusado por varios países de
cometer violaciones a los derechos
humanos se siguen haciendo eventos de
este tipo y digamos mundial en su
territorio
realmente es todo parte de una política
olímpica por así decir si no nos
hubieran hecho tampoco en
1936 en berlín los juegos olímpicos allí
o no si hubiera alguna forma esta
estructura o algún otro país
naturalmente china se postuló ganó en
este caso me parece que es un país que
tiene la necesidad de mostrarle al mundo
que lo que está haciendo y no podemos
dejar de descartar como bien se ha dicho
por france 24 en otras oportunidades que
la pandemia le viene muy bien al proceso
de cierre de lo que serían y de no
mostrar lo que es la totalidad del
universo chino hacia los deportistas
creo que no van a cometer los mismos
errores que tuvieron en el 2008 y su
apertura y la demostración de que él
tiene tenía algún tipo de inconveniente
en este momento en la crisis de
coronavirus le va a dar la mejor
herramienta como para que no salga mucho
del sistema chino de comunicación y de
lo que formalmente china quiere de los
países visitados carrey es que también
la globalización y la conexión el
comercio mundial creería que no permite
tampoco un boicot duro con todos con
todos estos países también los estamos
viendo en este conflicto que vemos
también me salgo un poquito el tema
preparar un poco de contexto hablando de
boicot en el entorno a ucrania occidente
contra ucrania digamos está el perdón
contra rusia eeuu de la unión europea
que no terminan de hacer acciones
concretas entonces estamos hablando de
un boicot blando porque realmente esto
afectaría digamos todo el orden mundial
del comercio mundial como lo conocemos
entonces digamos que sería más que todo
un juego de potencias de la boca para
afuera pero por adentro no porque no me
tocó en intereses económicos
es totalmente acertado lo que decís hay
mucho de anuncios y poco realmente de
efectivización de algunas acciones y en
definitiva no podemos dejar de pensar de
que china tiene algunos problemas con
hong kong tiene muchos problemas con el
tíbet mucho con mongolia sur las seis
vías la etnia uigur es un inconveniente
pero finalmente los países terminan
hablando del comercio termina hablando
de sus relaciones comerciales y es que
damos por enunciados que creo que son
mas magnificados o mal mal usados por la
propia cancillería china con un sistema
de dar de de dar pena o generar algún
tipo de pena del mundo hacia ellos pero
realmente no muestran la realidad hoy
por hoy no tenemos ni hoy porque sería
muy interesante ver algún deportista de
la etnia uigur ganar alguna medalla en
china tener algún mongol que estuviera
si el medallero o alguien de hong kong
que pudiera concursar realmente creo que
de eso nos vamos a quedar con las ganas
eso no va a existir
muy muy muy rápidamente de carlos pero
no quiero que se me quede por afuera
porque este boicot a china digamos así
sea diplomático y de la boca para afuera
como le estamos hablando y no acatar
en definitiva me parece que hay macro
políticas realmente de qatar tiene
algunos inconvenientes también en cuanto
a los derechos humanos hubo eventos en
cuanto a los derechos humanos pero creo
que está teniendo una alineación que es
diferente en lo que sería la
organización mundial es más cercana eeuu
del más cercano a inglaterra que es más
cercano a las posiciones en esto como
bien decía tú como bien hacía un buen
resumen rosa pérez la política en las
olimpiadas también juega